[Music]  so  [Music]  i'm colin the ceo and co-founder of  float  we built float to help business owners  like me get a clear picture of their  future cash flow  so they can make competent decisions and  build financially healthy companies  [Applause]  [Music]  it's our vision to mobilize the world's  healthcare workforce  what does that mean that means we  believe in a future where our technology  will ensure we get the right healthcare  professional  to the right place at the right time  [Music]  [Music]  hi i'm rory ceo and co-founder of one  year  no beer oinb we created  an alcohol-free challenge that is  ultimately about helping people  really change their relationship with  [Music]  alcohol  [Music]  you